this is a production of cornell
university
and i did change the title of the talk a
little bit because i don't agree but
underground is notoriously
for us you know
it's it's one of our favorite plants and
but anyways that that's not
the main point of the message i guess so
um thank you so much so yeah i i would
like i'd like to tell you a little bit
about what we do in my group which is
which has alias called biological forms
and function lab
and this is because we
are really trying to understand that
relationship between the shape that
plants have and
why they they would have that kind of a
shape
so yes we are interested in
how plants make their own shape the form
morphology
uh or structure in general the body like
that the entire sort of design features
of the body
um and that's that's the plant
development isn't it the the questions
of the plant development about that them
so i am i am as adrian said my
background is a parent development
development but the more you get into it
at least for me i start to wonder
why does it matter so much for the
plants to have that particular shape and
for the y element which is a more about
um
make the function
that that
that some kind of a structured function
that probably uh gets targeted in
evolution to
be selected toward
and so that why
it become quite important for me to
address once i become sort of
independent or probably i always wanted
to address that and then you know here's
the chance
you have your own group
um so that
to address that the form in a functional
relationship i particularly like this
sort of a
set of a phenomena that that allows a
very
uh
i my group really likes the morphing
structures that the structure that
change their shape their structure
struct structural properties in response
to particular environmental
or other input that's certain trigger
because that would environmental stress
causing the changes of the shape that
plants do that in so many different ways
and that gives us a nice grabbing point
of
right there is this stress so plants
change the shape the function probably
has something to do is dealing with the
stress
and
so one of the such structures we we
study is a plant shoot
and the other structure is a dandelion
diaspora
so dandelion diet 4
is something i hope you are all familiar
with played around as a kid that that
that you know you blow at it and then
they fly
um it's uh it's
we we chose it because definitely
there's some interesting form and a
function relationship there and we
probably don't know enough about it that
that part of that
their formal function relationship
actually well it didn't look like we
understood well but so dandelion
diaspora is one of the
probably nature's iconic flyers
uh probably one of the best possible
flyers uh in
in nature so they are possible flowers
meaning they catch the wind and the fry
they don't use
atp or muscle power to
aid the airfry it's a completely you
know sort of passive uh or a dead cell
so so this uh this structure called the
papas or plume
it's um bandurba here basically
um
they they are thought to enhance drug uh
and
believe it to act like a parachute
however if you look at
the uh structure
uh in detail that pro you know that's
quickly sort of crossed out as a
possibility because it's basically empty
space it's 90 percent empty space
um
this uh
bundle of hair so the question was how
does this you know highly porous
uh disk like you know uh that uh
this like um purpose
uh they they can aid uh flight of the
dandelions you do so well
um
and uh so
when you
want to understand the other function of
the plant structure in any structure
often it comes down to
through the mechanics because fluid
mechanics is that the field of study
which entangles
how a structure interacts with its media
in case of a plant it could be the air
or water or even soil if you are
studying a root
and so in case of a dandelion that would
be the air
and that's the body would be the purpose
uh so we wanted to
yeah study fluid mechanics um but for
for that that that structure to fluidity
interacts and basically and so the
starting point is really to get to know
the structure so we did quite a bit of
the 3d
scanning to capture the geometry but
also mechanical properties you know
measurement
looking into biochemistry of the purpose
and and so on and so forth and here is
the micro ct scan that we did of the the
dice for
the purpose so the purpose com is
consists of about 100
filaments hairs
however you want to call it
and a plus minus 10 so it's it's quite
sort of a consistent actually
length of the filament varies quite a
bit depending on the sample depending on
where they grow but um our samples are
uh consistently enough and it's it's a
you know about 1.5 centimeter across the
diameter
of the disk
and they get they are not completely
flat they they are spread around you
know across the 3d but sort of confined
to
the range of the 2d ness
and then so this kind of a
characteristic we did a capture and we
were wondering
what
aspect of these design features
structural designs are actually key to
that dandelions is such a sort of a
successful right
um
we did a lot of
numerical analysis and as i said the
structural narcissist we did a quite a
bit of a characterization but at the end
the uh proof of pudding
uh in fluid dynamics is really you look
at the flu you know floor movement
and so we
build our bespoke dandelion size
dandelion you know design uh
wind window tunnel so it's a vertical
because dandelion flies you know
vertically
and um
and then we popped that diaspora in
and this is what we saw um
if we are to
fix that
that that
the purpose and then do the long
exposure this is the picture we
get
um
so
surprisingly
that most of the flow even though it's
90 percent empty space most of the flow
goes around the entire purpose
and but a little bit of the flow goes
through but that creates the pressure
difference the pressure in
you know above or downstream of the
purpose is lower so that what
because of that that flow around the
purpose goes inside and it actually
circulates and then kind of stays on for
a while in there so there is a so this
is a longitudinal
like
medium section if you will and so you
can imagine this is in in 3d it's a hero
like like a wing of the circulating air
and
that that stays at the constant distance
it doesn't go away
that kind of you know air bubble some
people call or wind wheel um
creates
lesions of low pleasure
and
physics dictates
any object likes to move toward the
areas of it you know down the gradient
of the pressure so this could you know
explain that that the purpose and then
the seed attached to it would
move towards that that you know move
against the gravity i guess
toward that low pressure zone and this
could explain why dandelion diaspora can
try to well
so this happened to be that first time
the vortex ling
which is detached from body was over
served ever
it was theoretically
proposed
in a
through the dynamics textbook but it was
never proven or seen in the lab or in
nature and so that was exciting to my
fluid mechanics collaborator
collaborators but also so it happens it
so it it turned out to be a new writing
mechanism as well and the new flight
mechanism wasn't discovered in the last
50 years or or longer apparently so that
also caught the attention of
you know sort of
interdisciplinary uh researchers and um
um
and naturalist alike i guess
and so
so what is going on why why why don't
the air goes through that plenty of
empty space
that exists in the purpose well so there
seems to be something called the wall
effect at
work here
that when there is a porous structure
like purpose
um that
and then that's small and that is
actually experiencing a very slow
movement over here
um you can it's um it's a
that that air
media is
very viscous um
and so they don't really go through the
poor
as efficiently as
in a bigger bigger poor or yeah the
faster flow of the flow
and so what happens is yeah so that that
porous structure can almost behave like
a solid structure
and that seems to be happening with
standard ion
and so this is a diagram of uh
permeability in x y axis and this is the
drug um
coefficient in
y-axis and what you are seeing is uh so
the
permeability can increase
but actually drop it doesn't change from
a solid disk
for really long time
and then at some point it's it's just
too porous suddenly disaffected that
wall disappears and then boom all the
air goes through
and this is sort of that more bigger
diagram what's happening is something
like a 2d disc
porous 2d so like dandelion
purpose and you can see that the
mostly solid one looks like this and
then that vortex is attached and then
if it's too porous about 95 percent
porosity and so forth so that that
vortex doesn't form because all the air
goes through that that disk
and this is that happy you know sort of
a happy dandelion state
it's porous enough but not too porous
and
so the dandelions um
the structure is
represented by this this guy and the
dandelions you know porosity sits right
around that right before the cliff
cliff over losing this war effect
um
so we
thought yeah we wanted to identify yes
standalone purpose is a very complicated
structure
but
what aspect of that structure what
design features of that structures are
the minimal requirement for the
formation of the separate geopolitic
stream
and to do that uh we took the the
capitulation the building approach the
um
and we basically try to make that
that features that we think are
important just that with completely
different material and see if that's
sufficient so what we used was um
silicon vapor
and we identified that disk shape is
probably important
but also it's all about the porosity so
we made the difference that this
artificial purpose with a different
degree of a policy
and uh and then looked at it
the floor movement pop that into our
wind turbine and visualize the flow
and then sure enough that this is the
the the artificial the fake dandelion
purpose
uh with 90 percent porosity
and that that created the flow movement
which is almost i you know very very
close not identical but very close to
the natural thermal ion and it wasn't
the case with the other other porosity
levels
by the way we couldn't make more than 90
percent it was so tricky
to make what dandelion makes so easily
in nature
um yeah we we
only its own this was a project the pi
actually went into the green room at the
end because we had to come up with a new
ways of making
this uh this kind of object and and it
blocked so easily too maybe we made a 10
and then two survived
yeah so so yeah we don't have more than
the ion porosity unfortunately that but
yes
um so by having that
that
differential porosity gradient we can
also we could also characterize that the
phases of you know the porosity
uh and uh also the that that behaviors
of this uh throw movement that that how
that depends on the porosity i guess and
um so that when velocity is lower
this formation of the vortex link is
actually
quite easily uh lost
so steady is a steady formation of the
vortex and then that can lost to
unsteady nearly shedding um kind of
uh baltics behind and that's not good
for fright if it's like that what
happens is like you can imagine us you
know coin dropped they tremble and then
they fall a very easily
but if
that the baltics is very stable then
that does aid this you know sort of a
uh that hold up object that tattoo did
is to stay sort of aloft aloft and so
the dandelion
dandelion um samples that natural
samples are represented here in blue
and they all fall into this uh steady
range you know sort of um
yeah student um
object i guess
and i do want to emphasize this because
i'm gonna come back to this diagram uh
because you know as you notice that
those blue dots are quite close to that
border to the our city bridge
okay
so just
when we are um
starting to grab you know understand
that the flight mechanism of the
dandelion we had a visitor
uh included including mechanics who
whose specialty is the stability
of robotics and he he really wanted to
get into that kind of analysis of
dandelion purpose and then the flow
around it
and so what he did was he changed the
computationally the design features uh
quite a bit and then so like a simulated
that flow
uh behavior but also the pressure
gradient and and uh yeah so the sort of
giving us some ideas of what might be
the most preferable
most powerful aid for the flight i guess
like that if it's stable but also the
pressure grid it is strong
and you know that would be the most
favorable favorable and what he found
out was
that pelosi is a key but he
um
also found that out to that that that
the numbers of the filaments that
that being about 100 was was the key if
you if you change that too much then
then that it if there is a stereo
separated both
extreme but it's not as robust the
vortex
that its effect is not robust and that
was interesting because when you look
into the literature
what we find uh
in the counting of filaments number of
hairs in a purpose
of dandelion grow in
uk france or japan or china it's always
quite consistent it's like about 100
plus minus ten
and this might be because yeah it is
quite you know sort of a critical for
the flight function
and
considering i my background is a flower
development
i do wonder how
dandelion controls you know like make
sure that it has
such a sort of a specific number of
hairs
uh in the purpose structure
and so that papas um
is actually a modified sepal
and uh
it's uh
yeah it's about 100 filaments but it
it's it's it's a um yeah it's
uh probably that the molecular mechanism
development and mechanism of the making
of the seaport is the underlying you
know it's
underlying their developmental
mechanism
and so from from a making of a you know
few sea pulses which are you know
leaf-like organs to
you know making a 100 like more like a
hair like you know
organs
how
what happened there in the evolution and
also how do they
um
control the number of these highly
modified
of organs
that is a question and
we might be able to guess based on what
we know from moderate organism of how
simple numbers are on
but that's something you know if we can
tweak around uh to alter the number of
papa uh papa's hairs and then see how
that affects
a flight that's definitely something we
are very interested in doing however
doing um that kind of developmental
modulations uh re-engineering in
dandelion could be quite uh challenging
um we are not we haven't given up on it
but um
this is one of the reasons why we we
don't only work on them that i only
welcome arabidopsis as well and then
they address the similar kind of
questions
but
and actually do genetic engineering the
engineering of the structure and the
shapes and then then see how the
function changes and so on and so forth
but you know
today we are i'm gonna just talk about
the ion
so the reason why we are we were so sort
of a keen to study that
ion diaspora papa's function
um is is a not only that because you
know not
it wasn't completely understand
understood how why
uh they fly so well but also this this
observation that a lot of people noticed
um that dandelion purpose is not a
static structure it responds to the
environment specifically the moisture
level in the air
and if you drop like one microliter of
water
um at the base of the purpose hairs
within five minutes or so it closes
and this is a that that that kind of a
morphing observed in nature so in
in sort of a misty morning which was
very very common in um cities like
edinburgh
every morning was like that and they
would look like this
and then by that time like afternoon
early afternoon that air wasn't dry
enough so they opened up again and they
go back and forth in background force
it's completely deposible
and so we
set up you know our own mist chamber and
with mists um it's a slower the morphing
is slower it takes about 16 minutes but
you know it's it's again completely
deposible as well
and this morphing
environmentally induced morphing and
probably have a functional significance
because once
that moving this is not removing it's
half-moving it's a longer story but but
that
water droplet sort of dries very fast in
the window tonight so we couldn't keep
them like completely moved but anyways
even raise the heart moving what you see
here is that the vortex ring is
much smaller and also it's it's pro it's
very asymmetric and
yeah it's it's not a stable
uh structure and then that's something
you can see in this diagram so when i
talked about this steady phased unsteady
phase of um
[Music]
of the um
um the core of the disk uh in making
about exiting that basically so that
that
the blue
blue dots that you see in this diagram
uh is the wet sample and then that the
red
dots are the what i show before in the
earlier glove that they they stay within
the city range so
so that wet morph to close the purpose
is not a good flyer they don't make the
vortex
steady vortex too well
and it's also uh it also you know it's
it's it's also uh the case that that
closed
uh a purpose um diaspora uh flies faster
that falls faster
and so the fading a better city
is
higher
so
we
wanted to also understand how that would
affect the
diaspora function
a more like a real sort of a biological
uh settling which is that that purpose
is there for the longer distance
dispersal
and how does that affect you know how
does this moving affect
uh that
that function that wrong disperse this
distance dispersal and we try to do this
in the field
capturing the wind directions and the
speed and you know moisture level and
everything and then try to follow the
diaspora that gets
dispersed and maybe you can imagine it
was really really difficult
even measuring the you know chaotic sort
of a nature nature of actual real wind
was proved to be very challenging so we
we
resorted to um computational simulation
approach
and we use a world model which is widely
used to
calculate the
likely distances of um
uh
flying of
flying flying seed
uh its dispersal distance based on the
terminal a bit of velocities and uh also
the methodological data available
to plugging so what we used was there
are such data available for past 30
years
from many many different cities around
the world
and so we chose
about 10
european cities mostly from
uk
to see how
the danderayong
seed would fry
in their you know sort of normal seasons
uh of growth
and well
so here we have a four lines about but
open and closed dry and wet that's the
that natural
morphing seed
and uh we
rotate that so when that moisture level
is high enough and that's when we say
that's the weight phase you know wet
sample and then we we calculate as such
with the terminal velocity
and detachment speed and and so on so
forth to plug it in
um
and then so we want we want you to look
at a comparison of a green sample with
the orange first the orange is open all
the time that means it doesn't move no
matter the environmental difference
and so this would allow us to you know
probe the importance of the
environmentally sensitive and moving
and
the the left panel is uh the all samples
and then that right panel is that that
best of life top one percent fires
because longer distance
dispersal tend to come down to those
outlier best friars so we wanted to
capture those two
sort of levels of
the populations
and so if you look at
green bars orange it's actually not that
different at best of rice it's not that
different
and um yeah we were a bit scratching
your head oh right so no it's not really
it doesn't help them to go farther
um and then sort of we
we thought about it and we actually
divided that that natural the green uh
sort of a data to
wet condition samples versus dry
condition samples because it's up to one
you know in one individual diaspora that
when they they might assume that when
they might take off
is dependent on
those conditions so maybe we should
focus on you know this acceleration and
when we look at it it was very very
clear that
in the wet conditions that
the seeds don't travel that much at all
they stay in their own niche the
original niche where the parents
you know that were and uh the the dry
samples actually uh do do go far and
actually they do go further than
the whole sort of
population level
um
the best surprise and then
we
thought about it and then actually so
you know realize that
it's not like it's better always better
for
the plants to go as far as possible long
distance disposal is very risky
maybe they don't find a better niche
than what their parents were successful
enough to reproduce
and so maybe if the conditions are
favorable enough you do not want to do a
long distance disposal
and we start to look into
such a
possibilities
in the literature uh not just dandelion
but other species as well because when
we discuss this kind of a possibility
that we found quite a bit of
literature in animals
and this kind of a like environmentally
or biologically informed sort of a
dispersal base to to increase the chance
of running into a better or you know
like favor habitat is is called informed
disposal
that's that's um quite very known or
established concept in animal
service studies but
for plants at least
quite a few people told us that no it's
that implants it's it's really sort of a
thought to be passive
um dispersal is a you know sort of very
passive event
and so um
we but you know as a
being a plant development
biologist that didn't really sort of sit
well
in me because i know how
sort of resourcefully plants sense the
environment and then change themselves
to increase the chance of the survival
in a better you know reproduction
and so why would they just be completely
passive in such a critical phase of
their life you know
and and then so yeah that's why we
looked into
other examples of a informed disposal if
you will
and um sure enough there are quite a bit
of examples actually implanting kingdom
as well like some of the species even
make two different kind of diasporas
depending on the environmental condition
if it's a harsh condition dry condition
they make the wing and then they fly
further but if it's a nice wet condition
for example it just makes like
nice music to just you know ready and go
round and start sort of germinating as
soon as possible
uh or this asterisk species it doesn't
even make a papas unless it's a stress
for dry condition
and um so we think that that that
informed disposal doesn't happen
uh implants and also that the dandelion
might be one of such
example
and yes
so
and in the remaining time
i would like to tell you very quickly
yes
so what happens uh uh what makes this
more finger possible
um so the morphing uh came down to so we
looked at you know different parts of
this papa structure what is actually
mediating this small thing and it came
down to this base structure the floral
podium
uh floral base structure which is by the
way completely dead by the time of this
you know diaspora uh disposal
and uh and then so here you see sem and
this is environmental sem
that it's getting wet in the wet lid i
hope you can see the the hair moves
and yeah those are plucked off hair bits
and it's quite hard to see what's
happening but
if you can see the sideways this is a
cut you know in the middle this sample
is cut in the middle so you can kind of
see what's might be happening a little
bit more
but basically
oops
yeah
um
so in the dry state um oh by the way so
this is again cut in half and then there
is a cavity that where the piece used to
be they're dried out and it's a empty
cavity there so it's a ling like
structure
but it has the cap of a form a nectari
kind of a tissue on on top and there's a
musculature right in you know at the
edge of this cavity and then there are
like formal cortex tissues that's on the
side and basically this cortex tissue
expands sideways so this crease
disappears and deforms between these
cycle and that changes the angle of
these 100 hairs attached to it
and uh so this is a completely dead
tissue just the cell walls remaining
but different parts of it is expanding
the diff and the shrinking at different
weight and so this is the quantification
of that
that that the basquiatcha doesn't
shouldn't co-expand much at all and then
that cavity actually also doesn't change
the shape so much
and yet this side regions that cortex
regions they expand quite a bit and this
is sort of a diagram actually except for
the vasculature all other cap regions or
you know the side regions like they they
expand more or less the same way
um
and then so more characterization of the
movement of the expansions that we did
anisotropy and so forth
and uh we also you know looked at that
that
material composition as well because
those are all the polysaccharide plant
cell wall and how can they have
differential you know expansion uh um
properties uh swearing properties
because this expansion is induced by the
absorption of the water so we looked at
the material composition as well the
chemical composition as well and i have
noticed that the base of the um
the the purpose hairs have a ah
some special sort of a lipid enriched
sort of a phenolic compound phenolic
compound was everywhere by the way it's
a very autofluorescent as well so the
entire structure is very much sort of
um
yeah
it's a it's a phenotypic and endangered
structure with a sick secondary cell
wall and so on and so forth but yeah
there are definitely distinct domains
at the side and also top that where the
former next you know nectar used to be
um there there seems to be a specialized
um
phenolic compound there as well which
changes the intensity at a different ph
and so we think that
is likely to be failuric acid for
example
and so we
you know sort of um
identified there are about four
different material domains of this
structure
that seems to swell
when they absorb water differentially
and so again we wanted to know what is
the minimal requirement for this
structure actuator of this morphing to
function as such
and so to do that uh we collaborated
with a rescue buddha's group
um
in in france beyond and paris and what
we made was a simple 2d aximetric uh fem
finite element method model with these
four different
uh domains and we actually plugged in
the major the properties into the model
and then then looked for the reference
model that recapitulate the actual you
know sort of expansion tendencies and a
movement of the purpose that best and
and that was a trickiest process that
yeah we
took a lot of precautions to do so uh
and then identified one uh reference
model and once
i think the time is tight so i'm gonna
just
speed up we didn't do a one-at-a-time
parameter sort of um
um
space exploration to identify that this
difference model you know make sort of a
is a good reference model but also what
particular parameter is important uh for
example geometrical parameters
distribution that
that cavity how fixed they are is quite
important if we make the bottom beads
sort of free basically that that the
bottom bits kind of move on top of each
other and that changes that angle of
moving very very much so yeah for
example that actually ended up being
that
boundary condition we needed to fix that
that to to have a proper reference model
um um
but it really comes seems to be coming
down to a different
parameters that this this different
four different domains have that matter
a lot for the morphing and
uh with a digital you know sort of a
structure that we can do digital
mutagenesis it's very easy to let's feel
the cavity and then see how important
the cavity is and then you know fill it
and then sure enough without the cavity
that morphing is a very much decrease
and
how about maybe it's all about the top
bits of the cortex you don't need the
bottom bits
and so get rid of it and if not that
wouldn't work that wouldn't work you
need you need that that the cortex being
all around
and how about
but does it have to be very you know
specific uh
amount of the the cortex not really
actually this is a natural range if you
increase that bottom beats the cortex
cells more
you know that doesn't really change the
morphing capability
and so yeah we can do a lot of those
sort of digital mutogenesis and what we
ended up doing is all those four domains
are different in the rigidity and the
suitability we swapped all of them to
all directions
which really allowed us to identify the
minimal criteria for this you know sort
of a structure to work well
which is basically
the
musculature
so there has to be this this cavity
that's important
um
and then there is a vasculature that
doesn't do much it just stay put it
doesn't swell it doesn't shrink yeah it
doesn't move and then the rest of the
structure basically swell
and in response to water absorption and
that's it so so it turned out it is a
variation of a very commonly uh of you
know found uh um
um engineering mechanism that plants
tended to use uh it's called the bilayer
structure
that one side expands more the other
side doesn't expand as much or it could
be the other way around the shooting
cage yeah differentiating cage that
actuates the movement and but what is
unusual about this structure is it's a
link and a link like tube and that
allows that coordination of many many
you know appendages at the same time
which we haven't found an example like
this so much um
even though we are looking for it um and
so if you know some um yeah we are all
all years and we would love to hear
okay
so i think i am using up all the time
probably um
just sort of i'm gonna laptop now
um
so we um we are interested in platforms
and a function but there are so many
interesting functions shapes
and and so we are trying to focus on
this particular theme that we identify a
close the biological uh world uh and
also different scales that we are
interested in hair like slender body
structures
that
that's actually you know really common
in plant kingdom of course but also you
know beyond and plants basically are for
me a composite of a cylinder like you
know sort of stranded bodies
stems and you know um roots and but also
hairs on the surface of
those you know larger structures as well
and so it's multi-skilled and what is
interesting about that the srinder
bodies like hair like structure is that
they can confirm many different
structural functions like that's a very
good way like making a hair is a very
good way to
enhance that that that amount of that
ratio the increased ratio of
the surface area to volume and so it's
good for exchangeable you know moisture
or chemical compounds between outside
and ink and good for mechanosensing
bending erastically and so on it could
be prickly and good for defense and when
they come in many many
copies and they have you know more sort
of a hair the surface then that
functionality just explode with um
and what's interesting about them is
also that they tend to have a multiple
function like
in case of a dandelion purpose which is
a very hair haired you know
functional a structure it's good for
parking they can park they have a lot of
empty space among themselves so they can
pop and it's good for floor control but
also it's good for water capture
which i'm not gonna talk so much about
it
so far we haven't been able to uh really
uh convince ourselves that's
biologically important but they are very
very good at catching water
um okay i think i'm gonna sort of uh
stop
uh here but yeah that that hair like
structures you can find
everywhere close plant kingdom and some
functions are very very specific and
some functions probably are occur you
know across some some skills and then
that's also interesting the question
point as well
so yeah we are interested in you know
why why question the structured function
question but also how that once we know
that's the important you know sort of
structural features then we want to
focus our attention to the developmental
mechanism of that that making of that
that structure so i think that's
it
and this is the summary of what we do
i'm going i i talked about it so i'm
gonna skip to the most important slide
that foo actually really did the work
that i talked about
and a lot of assange goes to uh that the
past and the prison members of the group
um and uh
i really showed a picture of that the
main people who did the work i talked
today just now but like i call up you
know we collaborate a lot
uh with the experts of different areas
of our inquiry because um
we
are planning to developmental biologists
and we but what we want to do through
the dynamics
fabrications you know that dispersal
modeling through the dynamic you know
sort of um that that window toner essays
and so on and so forth so we
that for the work i talked about today
we collaborated very you know fruitfully
with um ignacio mario biores fluido
dynamics uh lab and they are sort of
members of these members of their their
lab a lot arizuki burrows group at leon
and the paris and um
the members of the group and a grass
goal for you know a window tunnel team
and uh also the yeah dispersal modelers
that that what we i we
i showed today actually we tried
ourselves but we realized no we need at
the expert advice so we reached out to
merida and james and so we are doing a
better more realistic modelling at the
moment and then that's that um
so before i shut up i would like to
really show who draw that project that i
talked about today so quark means
he is a pride mathematician slash of uh
fluido mechanics researcher he made the
window tunnel and they did all the
flight mechanism studies that he led
that that effort
it was a team
effort very much but he was you know the
driver and this is madison she's a a
very uh tarranted quantitative uh plant
developmental biologist who really
really sort of draws
the morphing project and uh with that i
would like to stop but i'm gonna leave
this one on
uh so my group has been trying uh very
hard to establish a synthetic biology to
kit tools protocols and
platforms because we want to be able to
do bio fabrication to change the
functional structures and that's usually
a pathway engineering it's not a one
single gene and
engineering and that's how we went into
synthetic biology
areas and uh yeah we've been making a
lot of
a lot of tools and i i i hope we hope
that what we are making are useful to
many others around the world so i'll
leave this here in case you are
intrigued by one or two of them right
with that thank you very much for your
attention
thank you naomi really fascinating talk
there's already a bunch of questions in
the chat
so i can read them
read them out to you
um
can we ask our question in person sure
go ahead okay people have their
questions in person you can also raise
your hand so go ahead and ask a question
okay may i ask my question right now yes
okay thank you thank you for very cool
and interesting
uh presentation i like it very much
but i have a question okay what was the
relationship between the density of the
purpose and the velocity it means that
the higher purpose
it means that the higher velocity or no
lower purpose has a
higher velocity do they have a
what was the link between them yes
so
um
the density of the hair you you mean
probably yes
is open that's sort of lower density
more porous
and that's a slower descent
and when it's closed and then the
purpose is less porous it doesn't it it
it falls much quicker which could be due
to well they did catch some water so we
tried we did a measure that it's very
minuscule difference but it might you
know it cannot explain these changes in
the
changes in the velocity of
falling uh completely but it would
contribute but the fact that it has a
smaller parachute
um
and when that the porosity is lower
the baltics that is this you know likely
to be helping this flight is not forming
and so there are lots of a different
aspect to why the closed form doesn't
fly as well as opened more porous form
but but um we think you know that that
this probably has a lot to do with it
okay
i mean
um
when they are open and has a low higher
amount of hair higher number of hair
in one hand they are heavier okay on the
other hand they can break the air
resistance and move better
they can break the air friction
so my question is that the higher number
of hair
increase the velocity or decrease the
velocity
so it's not a higher amount of a higher
number over here because the hair number
stays the same
but it's the velocity that changes
so when they are closed that they are
more closer to each other so
it doesn't have as much porosity
and
you might think that would help
that you know sort of acting as a world
better but actually uh it it
it seems like it doesn't really matter
as much for the wall effect because
up until you know quite high a high um
permeability the wall effect seems to
work as as well it seems like at least
from the numerical analysis
and um
the fact that it's uh it's it's close so
much means that parachute that the area
of the disk is smaller
so it's not really better for flight
oh i got it okay got it okay thank you
so much
thanks
um hello there
very nice talk naomi i really appreciate
it thank you i have a question that came
up after teaching years of plant
taxonomy and looking at dandelions under
the stereoscope and i have a picture
there behind me yes from one of my
dissections i got to get out of the
camera here
um
but you can see that this region oh my
finger's too big oh here we go
this is the mature
um stella and this is the flower but
look at this region right in here this
elongates hundreds of times
when it develops and i was hoping you
were going to talk about that today
because biomechanically that must be a
very interesting phenomenon it goes from
a few cells in that region to
what happens cell expansion and then
some kind of a drying mechanism where it
becomes a very rigid pole yeah right
yeah absolutely down thanks for bringing
it up that entire sort of development of
these structures especially kind of a
past development that completely uh
you know changes the shape like very
rapidly
the elongate the stalk both stock and
also the purpose hair proper
suddenly elongate
very very thick secondary circle highly
dignified
and it happens kind of a sort of a
when that that that the structure is
drying enough no that's not true sorry
yeah it's not about developmental
patterning it's a purely control of cell
elongation
and yeah so it's fascinating and this
talk we didn't talk about it um yeah i
didn't talk about it and we don't we
haven't published anything about it but
it is definitely it helps to center that
sort of orientation of the seed so
dandelion city is really like sideways
flying it's always pointing you know
and what's interesting is if you you
know sort of uh drop the seed
upside down like immediately if the
audience do you know they're right like
circumference it's almost
instantaneously it's like a cat
yeah yeah exactly yes yeah
so that stalk is definitely important
for that also while the fruit
puts the seed straight down however
we also looked at other asterisk species
which doesn't have the stock which which
are many actually that was my next
question because the genus origiron has
the papas but no stock exactly and when
we tried this upside down drop that they
were as effective oh
yes so we think it's more like during
the flight it's actually very good at
keeping it you know sort of a you know
but
yeah that's definitely yeah one of the
that remaining interesting question yeah
thank you
biomechanics of plants isn't it
fantastic
what can i say
naomi i looked up the identity of the
sepals right these uh pappas are
supposedly derived from sepals and
there's a paper just last year by
vig
verberg 2021 in plants that they use
some evo diva approaches and it is
homologous but it's a very weird highly
derived version of it that forms these
so there's some interesting
developmental issues regarding the
floral worlds and the identity of the
genes that are involved in those uh
structures yes and it's a spirally only
you know sort of a position it's about
three lungs of a spiral so they said
it's from the inner floral world inner
yeah okay that's what they said
which sepals should be the outer floral
world so i need to look at that paper a
little more carefully but
that's that's kind of wild yeah it's
that that is indeed world yeah but this
is a weird wild
structure i must say
you know maybe our developmental people
can inform me about what that paper is
telling us
got his hand up there yeah i had to go
back uh hi hello
i knew i mean that was a very nice talk
i i have a question i'm interested in
polyploiding of course uh terraxin this
island officinale is a polyploid series
with triploids and diploids and i'm just
wondering if you've looked at natural
variation for these structural
characters of the pappas and whether or
not cell size is affected and if so how
does that affect downstream phenotypes
that might be relevant for dispersal and
for the biomechanics you're studying
yeah thank you um so
so as i said as i mentioned the number
of purpose hairs seems to be quite fixed
no matter you know different country but
like completely different eco you know
system that people looked at however the
diameter
or that radius of this purpose
varies a lot a lot even on the same
plant i think it actually
and
and that is a bit of a question mark how
how much it affects because actually
that
sort of functional domain of the purpose
is not entirety but beyond certain sort
of mid-point or so the big distance
between two hairs become too wide so
they actually goes beyond the
cliffhanger of the
body it's actually the inner beads
that's doing doing the most of the job
so actually this um changes might not
matter so much before the flight
function
that diameter change however
it's very possible they don't have this
more thing when they grow in a different
ecosystem and so on we are collecting
samples from different you know sort of
environment they they that dandelion has
been growing and also we also made that
the dry you know treatment um
samples as well for three generations
also and then we are sort of looking at
it too um
and definitely those are those uh yeah
sort of interesting
yeah some of the really interesting
questions for future but but
surprisingly yeah um
it's so variable
in a given habitat as well and then and
then and then
very plastic i would say so yeah how
much of a fixed very clear sort of a eco
logical sort of echo type uh sort of a
difference that we can find etc i think
it comes down to can we find a really
good samples that really is stable and
then that you know sort of embedded into
sort of that
that way the habitat and we know where
they come from and and and so on and so
forth so i'm not sure if i yeah and so
i'm just curious do you know the ploidy
of the individuals that you've been
using for your modeling um yeah so we
collected these samples in the middle
like 10 meter away from our our lab
we go back there and then we collect it
but actually even that so dandruff have
about 500 known subspecies
and then trying to identify the sub
species to be honest we haven't
succeeded yet it's so subtle
that we are consulting that one of the
few you know um uk dander ion expert but
even they say no we have to see the
field grown leaves from
may to june or something like that and
then so we haven't been able to identify
uh yeah sort of but we have the samples
we have that you know the sample we
actually propagated in uh
for three generations and they have a
very uniform you know phenotype etc so
if we want to characterize their
fluidity level and stuff we do have a
very good collection of that that sample
so we can do but we don't know yet okay
thank you very much thank you
and
should i answer the questions in the
chat
how quickly do the seeds germinate after
the drop to the ground is it very quick
i was wondering if they are dropping
because the conditions are optimal for
germination
yeah so dandelion seeds in our hands it
was very difficult to germinate them
putting on the wet soil simply didn't
germinate them so well we actually had
to keep them in
water immersed for a couple of weeks
so our feeling is they really like wet
condition for for germinating
um
and uh yeah and
that that's as much as we know um but
that doesn't you know that doesn't go
hand in hand with you know the
preference for wet environment to fly
into and things like that
um how much natural variation is there
in dandelion papa structure yeah yeah so
i asked because taxi mercenary uh occurs
as a deep protosexual individual yeah
and triploid apple mix so this one is a
apomiktik
yeah it's it's it is yeah so maybe
that's that that would answer your
question maybe uh jeff but yes that we
know um we
uh
we did um
confirm that since celso is often
correct with priority yep
yeah
um
yeah serious size but we do look at the
whole structure and then that's that's
what matters about but yeah yeah
thank you for that uh we really should
be calling these fruits instead of the
seeds yeah it is a seeds yeah so
otherwise the fruits absolutely it's
actually and that's my comment i'm being
a a technical botanist
and then that that papa's [ __ ] is
actually appendage you know it's a
it's a it's not even part of a fruit so
we didn't go through how should we call
it
and diaspora i don't know why a lot of
people said about
general that refers to anything that
disperses so let's be
precise let's call it a
a keen some people say a keen but it's
derived from a bicarbonate ovary so
people in the aster ac invented their
own term sepsala so just say sip seller
that's the word we've used for a hundred
years okay great thank you yes i'm set
up i need a pretty one look at that
pretty simpsella
i like that it sounds very nice yes
upset okay thank you so much
you deserve our
ears discussion
thank you
i was wondering if air moisture changes
how easily a diaspora detaches from the
mother brand absolutely i did not
mention this but seriously oh yeah i
have this system on let me show you this
do you see
so this is a lottery floor big
window tunnel and if we put the weight
and a drop in fluorescence
whereas i'm sorry yeah and then so it's
like you know looked at how easily that
that that uh that sub-sarah
right
rise away
and um yeah with a window toner straight
in the air like without the turbulence
introduced that it was really hard to
detox
and so it stays on
on the pair for longer and at some point
though they seems to just drop and then
that that how they do that that in the
nature i think we really need to do a
bit of
that yeah the field of field of studies
but but yeah yeah absolutely i
completely agree and that would be a
very interesting study on its own as
well
such an interesting parallel with the
casper fruits yeah deficiencies that
occurs through differential dissection
of the different tissues yeah located in
different places in the fruit are you
thinking that something like a cadamine
and things like that
yeah
thank you yeah there's a lot of
strategies and clever engineering
mechanism in how france dispersed and
and yeah abs absolutely at least i am
fascinated
by that
thank you
thank you so much for all the questions
i hope i answered
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu